hello and we're glad you've joined us
for today's live webinar genomics and
cytogenetics michael ray in cns
neoplasia case studies to consider I'm
Robert Castellanos of lab roots and I'll
be the moderator for today today's
educational web seminar is presented by
lab roots the leading scientific social
networking website and provider of
virtual events and web webinars
advancing scientific collaboration and
learning today's events is also
sponsored by affymetrix a free matrix
technologies enable multi plaques and
simultaneous analysis of biological
systems at the cell protein and gene
level facilitating the rapid translation
a bench top research into clinical
routine use for human health and
wellness a few matrix part of the thermo
fisher scientific provides leadership
and support partnering with customers
and pharmaceutical diagnostics and
biotechnology companies and leading
academic government and nonprofit
research institutes in their quest to
use biology for a better world for more
information please visit a free matrix
calm so let's get started today you can
pose questions to the speaker during
this presentation and I've wanted to
remind our audience today how to go
about doing so if you selected the green
Q&A button at the lower left of the
presentation window you'll be able to
submit your questions all the questions
shall be answered at the end of the
today's presentation to reward to slide
window click on the screen icon at the
lower right corner of the slide window
if you're experiencing any technical
problems hearing this presentation click
on the support button found at the top
right of the presentation window or
report your problem by selecting again
the green Q&A button at the lower left I
would like to introduce today's speaker
stuart neil md an assistant professor of
pathology and laboratory medicine and
associates director of pathology
residency program at emory university dr
neil is a neural pathologist and
he received his MD degree from emory
university school of minnesota's atlanta
and completed a residency and
neuropathology fellowship at Emory I
would like now to turn it over to dr.
Neil for his presentation all right
thank you very much that was a very kind
introduction and I'm glad to be here
with everyone unfortunately we had a
little bit of technical difficulty
starting up so I'm going to be a
disembodied voice for you you won't see
me through webcam but I'm here to guide
you through this presentation we'll talk
a little bit about my experience in our
experience here at Emory doing some
clinical genomic and cytogenetic work up
in cns neoplasia and the main the main
focus of this talk will be through using
case studies to kind of illustrate some
of the ways that we have highlighted
important features of our cases through
some of the genomic workups that we've
done so again my name is Stuart Neil and
I'm an assistant professor and pathology
here at Emory and I I've done benedum
reef or a very long time I was an
undergraduate here I did medical degree
here and then my residency and
fellowship here like being at Emory but
certainly enjoy interacting with you
folks and so if you do have questions
please feel free to ask them either now
or or at another time so this is me I I
don't have any conflicts other than to
report that I do give some talks for
affymetrix from time to time in various
locations so again glad to be here
appreciate everybody's attendance and
and the kind invite from lab roots and
for Matthew metrics to talk in this
platform so Who am I really so it's
funny that I'm a neuropathologist really
getting wrapped into this stuff
sometimes that you know obviously I
trained in anatomic pathology also in
clinical pathology but my main focus and
in my early residency training was that
I would become a
anatomic pathologist but you know when i
started in neuropathology fellowship we
really at around the same time we
started getting into genomic workups of
brain tumors here at Emory and I can
tell you it was a transformative
experience for me I really really change
the way that I approach my work and has
given me a lot of insight into how how
the tumors behave how I can deliver
better information for patients so I'm
very much I'm very excited about this
type of about this type of information
and talking to you about it so again
what are we going to do today we're
going to talk about our experience here
at Emory and the use of genomic studies
in the assessment of cns neoplasia we'll
talk about some specific case studies
and then we'll also use those case
studies as a way to discuss some of the
investigative implications of the
information you basically can't do this
type of work without running into things
that maybe that maybe invite you to
perform translational work as well try
to try to carry some of your clinical
information and and and gain insights
into things that might implicate bench
research or translational research so
first thing just a quick introduction so
in surgical neuropathology we're
undergoing a real paradigm shift for how
we think of what we do and how we do our
work and really this gentleman over here
this gentleman here is dr. Harvey
Cushing he was a neurosurgeon about a
hundred years ago who really developed a
lot of the he and the folks he worked
with developed a lot of the terminology
and histopathologic classification
systems the sort of infancy of our
specialty was was promulgated by him and
the folks that he worked with and a lot
of the terms that we use today are
really still based upon what Cushing
described almost 100 years ago but in
the last few years we have seen a lot of
genomic studies people performed on
brain tumors both through things like
the Cancer Genome Atlas and through
other groups that have really
fed back into how our diagnostic
criteria are established and how we make
may gain an idea as to prognostic and
predictive information about the tumors
that we deal with so in just in the last
few years there's been a we've convened
a new w.h.o group to publish a wh 0
update that's just been put out in the
last couple of months basically changing
the way that we do neuropathology
diagnostics to incorporate genomic
information and so now when we issue
neuropathology diagnosis in the
diagnostic line we mentioned things like
idh mutations and one p19 kyouko
deletions things that really bolster our
diagnosis and get make them both more
accurate and precise so in a lot of
these new approaches have placed a lot
of our previous notions in a different
light so now when we think about older
cases when cases are brought to us who
may be in bed diagnosed 10-15 years ago
and the patient is is undergoing
treatment here at our Medical Center we
oftentimes wonder okay really what was
that tumor and sometimes we end up going
back in performing genomic studies using
ffpe based app platforms to try to get
an idea of what would what's the what's
the up-to-date diagnosis so we really
think a lot about all of our literature
going back before you know maybe 10
years ago even more than five years ago
really is put in a different light based
upon the information that we know now so
at Emory briefly talking about our work
up of course we we still look at at a
Chinese and we do immunohistochemical
studies on our on our tumors H&E is
still the foundation upon which we which
we base our later workup we test for
idh1 a TRX and p53 for infiltrating
gliomas on pediatric cases in particular
will we will perform a IHC 4 h3 f 38 k
27 mutant protein and then on
Angeles nomas we would perform gab one
yap one beta-catenin in p53 amino stains
on all gliomas we would basically do it
we would do a snapshot mutation panel
which is a multiplex pcr panel helps us
with a bunch of different idh1 mutations
the ith two mutations b-raf mutations
and a few other ones we we'd like to
adopt a larger NGS panel but that's been
in the works for a while now and we're
still working on it we do perform them
gmt met promoter methylation analysis
and then we do Anka scan our site of
genomic microarray ffpe based microarray
that that helps us in a number of
different scenarios that we'll talk
about over the course of today so at ed
Murray we performed on a scan on a
little over four hundred neuropathology
specimens over the last two to two plus
years the majority of those have been
infiltrating gliomas astrocytomas
alexander gliomas glioblastoma we've
also done a bunch of other tumors a
lower grade gliomas ependymomas what
used to be called primitive
neuroectodermal tumors now are called in
bryan all tumors and men in some men
angiomas and and i also mentioned that
we've done an increasing number of weird
oma's what i call we're doma so odd
tumors that perhaps would have would
have generated a more descriptive
diagnosis in the past but that we've
been able to use sign a genomic and
genomic studies to sort of tease apart a
little bit more about what they actually
are and how they may actually be haven
and in those scenarios i mean you know
you'd think they're rare right but but
in in in practice we run into these on a
actually relatively regular basis with
so these oddball tumors that give us a
good give us opportunities to get a
greater understanding of tumor biology
and and and we're working really outside
of an incredibly high volume laboratory
here we get a moderate volume of
specimen so we really dig into a lot of
the cases that we get not saying that
folks at higher volume places don't do
that but but we we we're able to take
some time and
and and really think about some of these
oddball tumors that we get and our
genomic studies have helped us gain some
ideas of what about what those things
may mean so just some general lessons
that we've gotten on performing this
type of testing we do preferred using s
ffpe material whenever feasible it
integrates well with our established
workflows here in the histopathology
laboratory so forth and it also allows
us to select areas to test to target
based upon what we see so we can avoid
areas with a lot of necrosis or coterie
artifact we can also say in instances
where there are areas of the tumor that
looks strikingly different we can test
those different areas just basically
doing dissection microdissection on
unstained slides so allows us also if
ffpe material we can pull cases from the
past and compare them to maybe to what
we have right now so our in our
experience pre-analytical heavily affect
the testing outcome we use here
unstained slides as our DNA source and
we review the corresponding H&E with the
pathologist and therefore select the
areas to test and and then that allows
us to check for tumor presence and
percentage and so forth so we know
exactly what we're testing and we also
make sure to make that the tissue is
properly prepared we avoid decalcified
specimens and we've also had problems in
august cannon slides that have been
baked for IHC basically have undergone
antigen retrieval for IHC our microarray
consensus conference is something that I
want to highlight a little bit so we get
together every week you get the anatomic
pathologist the molecular pathologists
cytogenet assists and our technologists
all meet weekly to discuss the cases and
that allows us number one to tackle
anything that may have produced a
problem case okay we look through the
pre analytic sequences to get an idea of
what may have be causing the problems in
our cases and then also it allows us to
all put our head together and agree on
the interpretation of the case and put
it in the context of the histopathology
and clinical
bindings and so forth so some more
lessons here transmitting this data to
pathologists and clinicians carries a
lot of challenges because the very
different people in our brain tumor
group have various different levels of
exposure to the information that we're
trying to transmit so it puts a lot of
emphasis on us number one getting on the
same page amongst our group and number
two transmitting that information in a
very easy to understand method for our
are treating clinicians and we all
sometimes we use tumor boards as a
platform in which to transmit that
information and then also say we're
doing some translational research
remember analyzing older material may
lead to an altered diagnosis and so you
need to be aware of that and also be the
have an open dialogue with some of the
treating clinicians if you are
performing older studies that maybe you
will discover something that you may not
have expected it's not uncommon for
older older cases to gain a
fundamentally different diagnosis if you
do a genomic studies on them so well
next we'll get into some of the case
presentations it's just selected a few
cases to illustrate the correlation
between histologic gnomic genomic and
other clinicopathologic information
we'll talk about the implications of the
diagnosis prognosis and therapy and then
we'll also explore some of the potential
applications into the investigative
realm from these cases okay so our first
case this is a man in his mid 30s who
presented to us with it with headache
and nausea and vomiting and was found to
have a left temporal peroxyl mass and so
what you see here and I'll go ahead and
highlight a few things what you see here
are okay all these little sticks here in
the background are axons and dendrites
of the of the native brain that have
been they've been joined by a bunch of
cells like these guys with relatively
rounded nuclei
okay and so this is a picture of an
infiltrating glioma basically all the
little sticks in the background that you
see are the native processes of the
brain and they are being infiltrated or
invaded by a population of cells that is
neoplastic and so it traditionally we
would tease apart infiltrating gliomas
based upon those nuclear characteristics
of the infiltrating cells so we would
say many of these nuclei look relatively
round so we would think maybe there is
an oligodendroglioma component to this
but some of these cells also have plump
pink cytoplasm and some of the nuclei
are a little bit elongated okay so maybe
there's an astrocytoma two component to
it too and so some people may have
called this oligodendroglioma some
people may have called it astrocytoma
many people may have called it an ala go
astray site oma which was fundamentally
a forum in many cases a wastebasket
diagnosis where someone couldn't make
the clear distinction of whether it was
an all ago or an astro so in the interim
we've we've delineated that using
testing for idh mutations and
particularly one p19 kyouko deletion one
can tell whether a many infiltrating
gliomas are oligodendroglioma zor
astrocytomas if you have an i-th mutant
tumor it is likely to be an idh mutant
astrocytoma or in oligodendroglioma and
you can use one p19 kyouko deletion
testing to make that distinction the one
p19 few positive tumors are in this
canary scenario with an i th mutation
all agoda under gliomas and those that
are 1p 19 q- fall mainly into a category
of idh mutant astrocytoma and you can
see the prognosis is different between
these tumor groups in fact it stayed
here on the slide eight years and five
years but we've seen people with
oligodendroglioma
survived much much longer than that and
some people with infiltrating
astrocytomas that are idh mutant will
survive a little bit longer than five
years too so we have you know there is
definitely a difference in prognosis
between those two groups and then
importantly if you have an ID h
wild-type tumor there are a bunch of
different subgroups of that but many of
them behaved incredibly poorly very much
like the old diagnosis of primary
glioblastoma and that has a very dire
prognosis 12 to 18 months so it's
important to make these distinctions it
really gives people a much clearer idea
of what the tumors prognosis is likely
to be so here's our art area view of
this case and what you can see is that
there are so remember blue is gain here
and red is lost in these areas that are
purple are LOH ok so what you see lots
of blue bars alright so that's a lots of
games and actually reflects the Polly's
only in this case there is a detected
idh1 mutation here but importantly
there's no looking at 1p and 19 q
there's no whole arm Co deletion and so
it most likely falls into the category
of an idh mutant astrocytoma and then
you can look here and actually has an
LOH on 17p where tp53 is located that
also goes along with idh mutant
astrocytoma so here it's more of a case
but we found a polypoid tumor that was
idh1 mutant negative 41 p19 hugo
deletion had LOH event on 17 p and so
our integrated diagnosis here would be
anaplastic astrocytoma wh 0 grade 3 idh
mutant the implications here based on
this histology as i was mentioning this
tumor could be called under the old
classification system a number of
different tumor types and so the problem
there becomes patients travel with these
these patients who have these brain
tumors they tend to travel to different
institutions they want to get the best
their care they can maybe they want to
get it on a clinical trial and so those
those cases would be reviewed and
perhaps given a completely different
diagnosis at a different institution and
so you know these patients are put into
a terrible scenario of well which one do
we choose and the clinicians are
confused and it makes it would make a
big problem in the past for disagreement
between institutions disagreement
between pathologists and the patients
caught in the middle so based upon this
genomic information though we feel like
we can get a much clearer diagnosis
that's a more easily transferable
between institutions and so we've also
run across some similar instances with
where tumors that had features
suggestive of a wildly different tumor
types ayla ganglia glioma also came out
with genomic studies very similar to
this and so we've not only been able to
look at tumors where we would sort of
expect this type of of differential
diagnosis but tumors that well we really
didn't look like an idh mutant
astrocytoma or a gang or an
oligodendroglioma where the genomics
really points you in a particular
direction so our integrated
classification offers greater accuracy
and precision moving forward and we have
to remember how what does this imply for
the tumors that we've diagnosed in the
past are the ones that are stored in
tumor banks you know this is a scenario
that's going to come up on a regular
basis not just in neuropathology but as
we as we apply this type of information
in other solid tumor types so our second
case similar looking thing here okay so
we start out here we see this is a woman
in her mid 40s who came with a headache
nausea and vomiting was found to have a
right frontal and to prank and we'll
mass and here we see again our our
background nura pill our axons and
dendrites are splayed apart and and are
infiltrated by round two at oblong
nuclei of an infiltrating glioma and so
our carry of you here again shows no one
p19 kyouko deletion okay
and and also detected a mutation of tp53
on 17 p now i'll tell you that with Anka
scan the we we don't always trust the
detection of tp53 mutations with Uncas
can now the idh1 mutations we've had a
lot of luck confirming those so we
certainly trust that the assays
detection of idh1 tp53 is a little bit
it's been a little bit harder for us to
confirm in some scenarios so but we also
see some other things with this with
this carrier view there are some other
abnormalities look over here on 11 that
looks pretty complicated so let's take a
look around there's more there are other
areas to this tumor that looks
strikingly different so here you have an
area of nuclei that is densely packed
lots of nuclei all crammed together it
looks much higher grade than the stuff
that we saw nearby and these tumor cells
are soaked densely packed and have so
little cytoplasm and look basically like
an undifferentiated tumor cell it makes
you think maybe this is an umbreon ol
neoplasm okay something that may have
been called a primitive neuroectodermal
tumor in the past so let's look around
our array data and get some better
information here so we see here on
chromosome 2 that we've got an
amplification of n mick and on
chromosome 11 we have the picture this
is the site of genomic microarray
picture of chroma thrips asst okay
multiple double-stranded breaks
producing gains and losses particularly
across this area of of 11 q so basically
the picture here is that 11q blew up
okay and it's been stitched together
back again like Frankenstein's monster
and in fact it's gained an amplicon as
well and this is an amplicon and ccnd1
or cyclin d1 and so we have an idea here
that maybe this chroma thrifts this
event is what triggered the umbral
neoplasm or what went along with the
dough I'm into the end Brian only a plan
them and so and maybe the chroma trips
this event is what also was associated
with the gain in cyclin d1 so we did
some amino stains for cyclin d1 and this
is the this is the interface area
between the infiltrating glioma
component over here and the umbral
component over here and you can see that
cyclin d1 is strikingly overexpressed in
the area of the Umbra no component and
negative in the infiltrating glioma so
the whole thing was idh mutant the whole
thing had an a TRX loss and was appeared
p53 mutant but we can see that cyclin d1
appears over expressed in the Umbra no
component so our integrated diagnosis
here was that we see at that time we
this was diagnosed prior to the wh 0
2016 so we use the term primitive
neuroectodermal tumor wh 0 great for
arising from an idh mutant astrocytoma
and our implications the diagnosis and
poor prognosis in this case is
reinforced by the genomic studies we
have a pretty clear idea of of that this
is not going to do well unfortunately
our combined analysis or offers some
greater insight into the potential
mechanisms and the drivers of tumor
progression in this case and the
genomics really explained the histology
and vice versa that in McCann pecan and
the cyclin d1 amplicon we usually
wouldn't see in a lower grade glioma and
what hear that that gives you an idea
that oh my i'm dealing with something
worse and then you look at the histology
and say oh well that's totally something
worse so you can kind of come from
either direction and say that this is
going to be an aggressive tumor and so
rarities like that really grant some
opportunities to bolster our shared
understanding of tumor biology what is
it that causes that tumor to develop a
chromophore this event and some
amplicons and unusual oncogenes that
that may that may make it behave in a
worse fashion our third case this is a
woman in her early 20s who presented us
with headaches maze the common theme
here and she was found to have a solid
and cystic left temporal
ass and so this is a low-power view that
really gives you an impression of an
infiltrating Glee glioma okay so over
here this less involved brain shows low
cellularity and but you can see over the
course of this slide okay we can see an
increased cellularity over to here and
so this is a picture of infiltration all
right these single cells are
infiltrating into the surrounding brain
to brain parenchyma and they're doing so
singly which allows you to get this
gradient of cellularity over space so we
have an infiltrating glioma and we do in
august can and it really looks kind of
weird we really don't have any copy
number of normality is here but what we
did have was a mutation and b-raf in
particular a v600e mutation so a couple
of things don't really fit here so
technically this is an IDH wild-type
tumor it doesn't have an ID H mutation
but it doesn't really fit into the
traditional idh mutant or IDH wild-type
tumor in that it doesn't it really is
quite cited genomically quiescent and
just has this b-raf mutation so we were
flummoxed on this one we first ran into
it we called it diffuse astrocytoma
w.h.o grade 2 IDH wild-type and we were
you know at first the histology and
genome profile seemed a little bit
discordant we were really expecting this
to have an ID H mutation instead we ran
into this b-raf mutation and we
considered an infiltrative variant of a
pilot citic astrocytoma but this this
tumor didn't really have any of this to
logic features of a pilot's at agganis
recite oma so we ended up just sticking
with diffuse astrocytoma grade 2 and
importantly the b-raf mutation does
raise possibility of some of target
therapy in this case so we kept reading
and we ran into other groups describing
b-raf v600e mutations in a subset of
low-grade diffusely infiltrating gliomas
and adults as stated here and some of
these tumor groups actually didn't
behave all that well they
ended up progressing and our tumor
actually did progress in a relatively
short period time so we're we're working
on seeing if this patient can be placed
on some targeted therapy but further
study literature as I said revealed an
emergent group of beer a mutant
infiltrating gliomas carrying some risk
of progression and this tumor did in
fact quote show clinical and pathologic
progression within a year's time and I
don't think the findings in this case
would have been fully appreciated
without a wide net attesting you you
know you would have to test this for
b-raf in order to find it instead of
just testing for idh or or just testing
for 1p 19 q se by fish it wouldn't have
given you the clearest idea of what this
is and what it might do so this of
course brings up the idea how many other
tumors have we seen like this are these
precursors to be wrath Newton gbms there
are subsets of gbms many of them are
epithelioid and there's some other
subtypes that have been described at be
ripe mutations and but we so we're
wondering whether this is a precursor to
that or whether it's something different
entirely so our fourth case here is a
man in his mid-40s he has a history of
medulloblastoma that he developed as an
adult actually about 10 years ago and
this is a over time he's been followed
with serial imaging he had he had had
seen market regression of his
medulloblastoma after after resection
chemotherapy and radiation so he's been
followed with with serial imaging which
noted this small mass growing in the
resection bed of the previous
medulloblastomas but very slowly growing
and really not showing the imaging
features of a Medal of blastoma so we
the neurosurgeons really curious about
what this what this was what was going
on so they went in and did a biopsy and
what they saw was really quite bizarre
so here we have a picture of the lesion
and we see here we have some ganglion
cell neurons here okay that are sort of
spread about willy nilly they're not
really well organized here but they're
quite mature looking
and then we have some cells that are
small and dark like these guys okay and
and those are looking a lot like
granular cell neurons from the
cerebellar cortex okay and then you have
some larger dark cells here that look
more atypical and are and are a little
bit more concerning may be infiltrating
astrocytoma but it doesn't it's an odd
picture overall because the whole
architecture is messed up of this it
doesn't look like normal cerebellum it's
just a bunch of cells some of it you
might see in normal cerebellum and some
of which look more neoplastic that are
just thrown together okay so we went
back and looked at the original
medulloblastoma and this very much well
looks like a medulloblastomas very
distinct from what we had though these
are tightly packed cells that are very
blue not showing lots of cytoplasm look
very in Brian allure primitive not very
well differentiated and highly
proliferative and so it would confirm
the original diagnosis but we also
figured what it really doesn't look like
what we have so we did Annika scans on
both of these and what we found was that
the two were basically identical I know
you see there's a little detective
mutation over here that was uh that was
a low confidence mutation wasn't
actually likely there but the rest of
the findings look fundamentally
identical and so basically both of the
tumors are signed genetically incredibly
similar and so we have nearly identical
microarray data that despite this
drastically different clinical
radiographic and histopathologic data
suggests a relationship between these
two masses and in fact if you'll if
you'll look back on 17 we see that
there's a loss of P and a gain of Q
which goes along with an ISO chromosome
17 which suggests goes along at least
with a group or group three or more
likely a group for tumor we don't see
the findings also that would we didn't
see findings
would have suggested a Wintour a sonic
hedgehog pathway tumor and so what we
basically came up with in this case is
that this is a modular blastoma with
extensive maturation we're seeing mature
tissue elements that are derived from a
medulloblastomas and it's so it's
probably similar to what's been
described in neuroblastomas more
commonly in the past that these tumors
can mature and and show different
clinical pathologic behavior after the
maturation phenomenon occurs so in this
case and are in are in art to our
knowledge this is our first microarray
done of this incredibly rare phenomenon
and medulloblastoma it's only been
described six or seven times in the
literature prior to this and I don't
think anyone's done a microarray on
those cases so what are the implications
here so what determines this
dramatically different histologic and
behavioral appearances in these two
sided anomaly identical lesions so could
it be changes that we're not looking for
obviously we're not looking at
epigenetic data would be nice to look at
the methylation profile of these two
masses could it be some mutation or
fusion that's that's being dropped in
maybe the the the mature lesion we don't
know because we haven't been testing for
those and what's the comparison with a
neuroblastoma would can we really take
the experience for maturation and
neuroblastomas and apply this to this
lesion or not but really this case
highlights the power of comparison
between tumors even across long periods
of time that original medulloblastoma
was about 10 years ago using sfp based
broad-spectrum genomic analysis it's the
broad spectrum that really shows how the
abnormalities basically match up in
between the two tumors so our fifth case
this is a woman in her early 30s who
came with again headache lethargy and
she had a left frontal enhancing mass
and what we see here is densely packed
highly atypical tumor cells okay these
guys here and here and they have
nucleoli these little prominent nucleoli
okay and they also have these rounded
eosinophilic inclusions these pink
things pink blobs in the cytoplasm and
so when you see this type of appearance
number one looks very malignant number
two these rounded eosinophils areas make
one think about a rhabdoid tumor and in
the cns a rhabdoid tumor is an atypical
territory rhabdoid tumor okay that's
what we call them in the cns and so our
carry of you here again shows on the on
on this tumor we see just a few
abnormalities a gain of eight okay a pic
three see a mutation on chromosome 3 a
little loss on 13 and then a focal loss
on chromosome 22 which is where smart be
one is located and we'll look more
closely at chromosome 22 and we can see
a homozygous loss right at smart be one
so the smart be one has just been
chopped out of this a trt and so our
august can findings again homozygous
deletion at 22 q1 one locus as smart be
one that corresponds to smart be one
protein loss to take it by
immunohistochemistry and there's an
absence of abnormality suggested with
other two that might suggest other
tumors and we also see a few other
abnormalities detected by august and our
integrated diagnosis was a typical
territory rhabdoid tumor wo grade 4 and
this patient had been noted previously
to have a low-grade glioma in around
this location so we've took a look
around in this in this the tissue that
we got in this case and so there's some
more so in the surrounding cortex we saw
neurons okay some of which had this sort
of fibrillar cytoplasm that suggested
maybe that they had neurofibrillary
tangles in them and then there were
extra cells added on top these guys okay
that looked pretty banal but looked more
like an in
Trading glioma okay and these these
neurons sort of scattered around my
makeup may bring up the idea of a gangly
of glioma but we this was actually
cortical brain tissue and was we didn't
we didn't feel convinced that this was
actually a ganglia glioma and what what
was most interesting about it was that
by immunohistochemistry these small
tumor cells here had lost smart be one
so we actually did an august can on that
component as well and we thought well
you see here basically there are no real
abnormalities outside of chromosome 22
and what we saw in 22 was a loss a
hinnies I guess loss not the homozygous
loss that we saw in the true a TRT but a
hemizygous loss in the region of smart
be one so our low-grade tumor shows a
hemizygous deletion at that locus and
then absence of other abnormalities seen
in the adjacent 80 RT and to us this
suggested that this lesion may be a
precursor lesion to the 80 RT and so our
integrated vinyl diagnosis was a typical
territory rhabdoid tumor wh 0 great for
arising from a lower grade smart b1
deficient neoplasm and so the
implications here tho those some others
have reported 80 RTS arising from
histologically lower grade neoplasms
some people have said that there are
ganglia gliomas that have been seen in
association with 80 RTS and some other
tumors as well we were able to
demonstrate a side genomic relationship
between these tumors using our our array
and then we also showed that there was
evidence of sight of Sunday genetic
progression based upon the additional
abnormalities seen in the array on the
80 RT to go along with the
histopathologic changes that showed that
the aprt was a high-grade lesion and the
lead the the tumor next door was
relatively low-grade the proliferative
indices were markedly different between
the two it was it was quite clear that
the 80 RT was demonstrably different
than the lower grade tumor but this is
another example of some of the
exploitive
our broad spectrum testing on
histologically distinguishable
inseparable neoplasms you wouldn't
really be able to do this very well
without histology being able to tell you
distinctly these are different tumors
and then to be able to go in and and do
testing on the two separate areas so in
summary the advent of genomic testing
and brain tumors has already led to a
market changed in our diagnostic
approach we have gotten to the point in
neuropathology here at Emory that we
oftentimes end up waiting on the genomic
testing results before we make final
diagnosis on on a fair number of our
cases some cases are things like
glioblastoma xand the in a in a
traditional clinicopathologic scenario
with radiographic data to back you up
and pistol histology that's very
straightforward we usually will make
that diagnosis without having to wait
but lower grade gliomas we almost always
wait on the genomic data and then a
number of other tumor types we may end
up waiting on on genomics as well so in
talking with other folks many large
centers are performing broad spectrum
testing on most tumors detected or
treated and some smaller centres I can
understand there's going to be some
there's going to be some some challenges
they're grappling with the need to
address this information while also
operating in an environment where money
is just doesn't fall off trees so you
know it it and then also you know
clinicians are going to have varying
levels of interest or exposure to this
data and so it's going to put a lot of
impetus on pathologists to try to try to
drive some of the some of these changes
by following the new wh 0 diagnostic
paradigm I have some experience in
working in some smaller Center myself I
don't just do neuropathology here at
Emory I do general surgical pathology at
a large public hospital in downtown
Atlanta Grady Memorial Hospital and so I
end up having to make decisions on you
know in cases where you know the patient
maybe doesn't have insurance or you know
there are much greater costs concern
turns where I have to make you know
decisions about what what testing am I
going to choose which am I going to
actually run an array on I'm much more
much more careful when I'm at Grady
whereas at Emory you know we're in an
academic environment are much more
aggressive and testing a lot of our
tumors so so i would say that when
you're at a smaller center it's
important to note the necessary
components what i view as necessary
components for implementing this type of
testing i do think it's it's important
to have something along the lines of a
consensus conference where folks can get
on the same page about what this data
means for the tumor types it's going to
be very hard to just take the
information from say an outside centre
and and and and completely integrate it
with what you're seeing histologically
that may be difficult and then really
making sure that the correct information
gets transferred onto the treating
clinicians it's just important to have a
mechanism for everybody to kind of go
over this and to really delve into some
of the pre analytic problems that can
that can lead to difficult or impossible
to interpret data so in general broad
spectrum testing opens up numerous
avenues for improved diagnostic and
investigated capabilities really opens
up your eyes as to what's possible and
some opportunities to to get a better
idea of what drives tumor behavior and
biology highlights features that
wouldn't be readily appreciable by
histologic analysis it I like to say it
answers questions that you would
anticipate as well as questions that you
may not anticipate so just like I said I
showed with that be Rasputin
infiltrating glioma in many cases you
would have just anticipated to ask the
question of is this idh mutant or not
and is there a maybe a one p19 kyouko
deletion or not but in that instance
doing some more broad spectrum testing
not just answered those questions but
answer the question of is there a beer
at mutation which you may not have
thought
ask so really this type of testing
alters our understanding of tumors past
present and future really makes it makes
it very different in terms of
interpreting data from the past
interpreting data that perhaps that you
that that on patients that are referred
to you from outside institutions and
makes you think about differences of how
we are going to approach these tumors in
the future and this type of testing is
likely to only gain an importance in my
opinion so we couldn't do this without
the support of a lot of different people
I was basically trained in doing these
types of this type of testing by these
two individuals Deb sax and Mike Rossi
here at Emory and then these are some of
the primary technologists who do this
testing I'm leaving off numerous members
of our site oncology cytogenetics lab
who are integral in making this testing
a reality and to those folks I offer my
apologies it's not it's not because I'm
being mean and then folks in
neurosurgery who have been very
supportive of us and then my fellow
neuropathologists here at Emory who have
trained me and and are extreme extremely
helpful in making this testing a reality
and then folks in molecular pathology in
neuro-oncology and our pathology and
dramatics group who also helped us out a
tremendous amount so that I'll thank you
again very much for inviting me to give
this presentation I hope this was a
beneficial experience for you and I
apologize for the technical difficulties
and the fact that I am a disembodied
voice but I'm certainly more than
willing to answer your questions at this
point and if you do need to get in touch
with me I'm actually on the Emory
website you can email me as well ok so
with that I'll turn things back over to
our moderator I thank you so very much
dr. Nealon thank you very much for your
presentation and bringing forth case
studies today a quick reminder to our
audience and how to submit questions
simply type your questions found by
clicking on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
dr. Newell answers many questions today
as time permits so dr. Newell we do have
a two-part question to kind of kick us
off today you mentioned a comparison
with a ten-year-old ffpe sample was
successful and what is the oldest as a P
simple that they've analyzed and is
there any concern about sampled
aggression that's it that's a very good
question and if I remember correctly
we've gone back 10 to 15 years and
gotten good FFP data now since we're
doing this in a clinical stand from a
clinical standpoint we basically attempt
it whenever there's a clinical question
that may be answered by this type of
testing so if we were pursuing this from
a more translational perspective we
would be testing of course tumors that
are go back much much further 20 30
years and and my mind to my knowledge
folks have had success in doing that for
older ffpe blocks but for us doing this
clinically it actually has been only 10
to 15 years that we've that we've tested
up to this point all right well thank
you so very much on the uncle of skin
potentially can pick up a lot of CNVs
such as the magis deletions and
applications what criteria do you use to
select a clinically significant ones
another very good question so first
things first you know you need to have
criteria for for what do you report in
general so for us in house we don't
report loh events that are less than
five mega bases and unless we can be
sure that for instance that that loh
event is surrounding maybe a gene or a
locus that is known to be incredibly
important in that tumor type but most of
the time LOL under five mega bases we
wouldn't report
and then we also again for some say
you're looking at a at a leukemia
specimen or that where you may be
interested in icarus the icarus locus
there you know there's only going to be
a few probes that you would be able to
to analyze so in that sense you would be
you would have to be very careful using
just a few probes to try to determine
whether there's a deletion or not but in
general I would state that the answer to
your question is the best way to figure
out whether whether something is
clinically significant or not is to have
the type of consensus conference that
I'm speaking of where really you can get
multiple different people in the room
where some folks are coming from
neuropathology some folks may be from
neuro-oncology and then oncology site of
geneticists and molecular pathologists
who will bring a wealth of information
about what really is the significant
findings in these tumor types and really
what's going to feed back into the
diagnosis of prognosis so it's not
really an easy answer but I think it's
important to make sure as many people as
many brains as possible are applied to
this information because it is very
complex and it can be difficult to
figure out what's significant or not
thank you our next question is the tumor
had ranjini posed a major obstacle and
characterizing these infiltrating glands
um so yes and no so tumor heterogeneity
in terms of areas of necrosis could
certainly produce a lot of difficulty in
characterizing these gliomas however
instances where you're dealing with
maybe a night eh viewed tumor where your
main question is is there a one p19
kyouko deletion or not the majority of
those tumor cells are going to show a
one p19 kyouko deletion if not all of
them I know there have there actually
some folks I know at Brigham and Women's
who are doing some some single-cell RNA
based testing on gliomas who can tell
you oh there's a lot of heterogeneity
and all of these things
from a clinical standpoint we really
haven't had a whole lot of difficulty in
tumor heterogeneity posing an obstacle
to getting us a usable data well thank
you so very much and our next question
is do report long stretches of the homo
glossa t if this includes a cancer gene
so similar to what i said before are our
cutoff is is five mega bases and we
basically do that it's based upon the
idea that there will be some
homozygosity in general we also you know
that the testing platform is is probably
least specific in dealing with with
areas of homozygosity so but an answer
to answer your primary question yes if
there's a long stretch of homozygosity
that includes a cancer gene we would
report that nope no questions asked okay
thank you so very much here our next
question is here is why do you use if
Ivan being as the cutoff so I answered
that a little bit in the previous the
previous question but some places use 10
mega bases but in our experience there
are going to be areas of homozygosity
that the platform picks up particularly
around the ends of chromosomes and
around centromeres that are basically
just noise in the system and as far as
we can tell so we use five mega bases
just as our way it's it's it's it is
relatively arbitrary but just a way for
us not to be reporting lots of small
areas of homozygosity that may not be
real or may not be clinically relevant I
know thank you so very much and we have
time for a couple more questions here
and do you do do you include the the
chiro view that case image in your final
report uh we don't currently put images
into the final report the way our our
final report is structured is that we
basically have an interpretive component
we have a
a free text area where we try to give an
interpretation of the data overall
highlighting certain things and given an
idea of what's clinically relevant we
also produce a table listing all of the
diet of the areas that have been
detected as a verrin and that we have we
have agreed are clinically relevant and
then we give site a genomic nomenclature
as well and then a bunch of disclaimers
and so forth ha thank you so very much
here and our final question here for
today is can you list all the diagnosis
again and didn't catch everything sure
so if the first one is an idh mutant
infiltrating astrocytoma the second one
is an idh mutant infiltrating
astrocytoma with a what was called at
the time a primitive neuroectodermal
could tumor now would be called a CNS
and Brian all tumor CNS and Brian Leah
plasm and then third let's see there was
a beer at mutant infiltrating glioma
fourth was a module medulloblastomas
extensive maturation and fifth is an
eight ER t arising from a lower grade
smart d1 deficient neoplasm well thank
you Destiny's once again for answering
the audience's questions here do you
have any final remarks as we wrap up
here today well I just I really
appreciate the questions and I had a
great time doing this and please if you
if you need to ask me any questions
further on down the line feel free to do
so I appreciate everybody's attention
and showing up today to hear me thank
you thank you very much and like to
thank the audience for joining us today
for the interesting questions questions
we do not have five time for today will
be addressed by the speaker after the
presentation we'd like to thank our
sponsor as well a few matrix for under
fighting today's educational webcast the
swept past will be able to be viewed on
demand through March 29th of 2017 lab
roots were lurching via email when it is
available for replay and we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event until next time goodbye